they cleaned the microphone they spaced
everyone out it was march the 7th this
year
and they were incensed about the 1 pay
rise in the nhs
i think it's outrageous that somehow
this is deemed illegal
karen the organizer even wrapped things
up when the police in manchester
told her to as i was leaving police
officer called me to one side and said
can i have a quiet word i want to give
you a ten thousand pound fixed penalty
notice karen will not pay
and is taking it to a judicial review
somebody calculated for me that if i
used my 1
pay rise to pay it it would take me 56
years
of that 1 to pay that fine off
stay there stay there whether the police
have been breaking up parties
you shouldn't be here no you shouldn't
be here so why are you here
because you've been bored and we want to
have fun or just challenging people who
have been out and about
everyone has had to try and keep up with
the rules
in the past 12 months the covid
regulations
have been changed at least 65 times in
england
more than 85 000 fixed penalty notices
have been issued
since march last year of those cases
that reached court
the crown prosecution service found that
just over one in four
had been incorrectly charged now the
joint committee on human rights has said
the covert fines have been muddled
discriminatory
and unfair what we're saying to the
government is that they should allow
all of those 85 000 fixed penalty
notices if somebody thinks it was unfair
they should now put in force regulations
which say
you can challenge it while acknowledging
the police have had a very difficult job
the committee concluded that young
people particularly from ethnic
minorities
have been most often the ones fined so
people of my age
don't really care they will be fine they
will pay and if they want to party again
they would wear
i think no one really knows like what do
you get fired like how many is it
because there's so many like different
things you're here
yeah like if it's under like 15 people
or something in the room
it's a different 200 instead of
800 i honestly don't know what i get you
should be punished but if you
try just if you find a student 10 grand
that's their life
like messed up for a while so i don't
really think the phone's reasonable half
the time
where covid fines have been incorrectly
issued police leaders say they will work
to rectify the mistakes
while still enforcing the rules when
they need to do so tom parmenter
sky news manchester